there's a lot of messed up prisons
around the world but I found this one to
be the most disturbing it's a fictional
Prison from the show Andor and it's
designed specifically for convicts that
are assessed to be labor worthy it can
hold up to 5,000 inmates and they're
grouped into these work teams and day
after day they work together to assemble
these mechanical Parts but no one
actually knows what they're building the
genius part about this prison is that
the control mechanism is built directly
into the architecture for example these
Tung stoy steel floors can fry you and
it can even kill you it's also designed
to make the prisoners think that they're
being constantly watched and this idea
of constant surveillance makes them
incredibly obedient and as we studied
prisons more and more a very disturbing
idea started to pop up the purpose of
Prisons is to detain people
philosophically it gets a little blurry
when you start thinking about you know
if the purpose is to punish or to
rehabilitate but functionally it's a
place meant to contain prisoners and to
keep the rest of society safe but what
happens when the architecture itself
becomes the surveiller the detainee and
The Punisher a portion of this video is
sponsored by
milanote this is the panopticon it's an
architectural concept for prisons from
the 18th century by the philosopher
Jeremy benam the word panopticon derives
from the Greek word for allseeing and
it's designed around a central
Watchtower where the guards can always
have a view of the prisoners but the
prisoners can't see the guards this
creates the illusion of being constantly
watched meaning there's a higher chance
the prisoners are going to behave and
self-regulate and the entire facility
can be monitored by just a few guards so
it's not just physical containment it's
kind of a psychological control and this
complete erosion of privacy can lead to
anxiety paranoia and a loss of dignity
although this exact design was never
implemented we've seen variations of
this concept all over the world most of
these prisons were shut down but I think
this architectural typology solidified a
broader social message and how Society
perceives prisoners it suggests that
surveillance and control are essential
in managing criminal behavior and it let
us down a path that focus on punishment
rather than
[Music]
rehabilitation
this is the sound of solitary
confinement this is where they send
prisoners who are considered to be a
threat to security or other
inmates it's an empty room and the
average size something around 6x9 ft
it's mostly windowless without any views
or sunlight prisoners spend up to 23
hours at a time and for 1 or 2 hours a
day they're let out into another
isolated area and when you listen to
stories of inmates who spent time there
what's amazing is just how quickly their
mental state starts to deteriorate and
to understand why let's take a look at
another type of
detainment everything in the room is
white including the floors beds clothing
lights and even the food is white the
rooms are completely soundproof and the
lights are designed to remove any kind
of Shadows it's called The White Room
torture
and it's a form of psychological torture
using complete sensory deprivation and
it can leave permanent psychological
damage one political prisoner who
endured white torture for 8 months
couldn't even remember the faces of his
parents and that's because a normal
brain needs interaction and activity for
the cells to grow and studies show that
when you remove stimulation the brain
freaks out and it can cause anxiety and
depression and because the brain is
constantly trying to establish patterns
it can also lead to hallucinations in
fact just 15 minutes of sensory
deprivation can lead to anonia which is
the complete inability to feel pleasure
and of course solitary confinement is
not as controlled as a white room
torture but there's just so many
parallels that it's kind of hard to
ignore solitary confinement can also
leave permanent psychological and
physical damage and despite the backlash
from multiple human rights organizations
it's still very common practice in
prisons throughout the world especially
in the US in all these cases what's
really interesting is that architecture
is not used just for physical
containment or a functional necessity
but it's used for psychological
dominance two he seems to have an
818 can you feel
this
4814 avoid the 714 and and I think this
is where the Dilemma is especially for
architects architecture at its core is
supposed to serve the public it's
actually ingrained in the profession and
it's even in the aia's code of ethics
Architects must uphold human rights in
all their professional Endeavors and
make the built environment accessible to
all and respect the Dignity of all
people yes we need prisons to protect
the broader public from criminals but
the line becomes kind of blurry when the
architecture is designed specifically
for the purpose of causing harm to
another human being
if you've been following this channel
you probably know that we use Milano to
organize all of our research and they're
also sponsoring this video we use
milanote from the brainstorming
storyboarding to the final research and
pretty much for anything that needs to
be organized visually I've even created
my own template boards with guidelines
so that we can copy it over every time
we start a new project some of our team
is remote so being able to share and
edit the boards in real time during our
meetings makes everything so seamless
it's replaced a lot of apps for us cuz
it's super Dynamic and simple it's
definitely improved my workflow so I
think it's going to help you as well no
matter what industry you're in it's
completely free with no time limit so
you can sign up using the link in the
description and let me know if you guys
like
[Music]
it this is considered to be one of the
most effective prisons in the world the
Halen prison in Norway and when I say
effective I'm talking about the
recidivism rate which is the tendency
for a convict to reoffend Halen has a
rate of 20% compared to the
76% which is the average for prisons in
the US and of course there's a whole lot
of factors outside the prison
environment that impact this number and
many prisons in the US are actually
operated by private companies who make a
profit from the prison po population so
maybe there is an incentive to keep them
in the system but Halen's success is the
result of actually a pretty simple
idea normality meaning the prison should
resemble life outside as much as
possible they have workshops music and
recording studios a worship room they
even have a place where your family can
stay overnight as of 2012 Halen had 340
staff members for only 22 28 inmates
that's more than one per prisoner kind
of the opposite of the idea of the
efficient automated control that we see
in Nina
5 but this prison is in Norway so is it
even a fair comparison Norway has about
a 160th of the population of the US the
incarceration rate is about 75 per
100,000 people while in the US it's
about 700 per 100,000 ,000 which is
about 9.3 times higher than Norway this
also means Norway can spend a lot more
money per prisoner Norway spends around
$127,000 per prisoner a year compared to
just
$25,000 in the US but actually it wasn't
always like
this before in the '90s Norway also had
a recidivism rate similar to the us
70% and a rising prison population and
in fact it was because they found these
to be so not coste effective in the long
run that they took a hard look at their
approach during this time there was also
more and more research coming out that
talked about the limitations of prison
models that are focused primarily on
punishment also there was just more
awareness around human rights issues and
more awareness around the treatment of
prisoners and the people actually start
to push for something something more
ethical and so all of this led to some
major changes in their approach where
they went from a punitive model to a
rehabilitation model and that actually
had a huge impact on the architecture
most of these prisons fall into one of
these categories circular or the
panopticon layout with a central
Watchtower and cells along the perimeter
Courtyard layout with a structure
encircling a central open area
triangular layout with triangular
structures connected by a spine linear
layout with rows of buildings stacked
along a central spine x-shaped layout
with a cross-shaped form and the radial
layout with branches that come off a
central point apparently they'd rotate
the prisoners to these different arms so
they can never familiarize themselves
with where they are and the prison and
Andor would fall into this category but
with the sleeping Quarters at the
perimeter by consolidating all the
facilities into a single continuous
building it maximizes efficient icy cuz
you can limit the circulation to just a
few hallways which means you can be a
lot more efficient with your
surveillance in narina 5 this is taken
to the extreme and even the cells are
stripped to the Bare Essentials and
designed for maximum efficiency and
control all the basic amenities like
beds toilets food water are neatly
compact in the cell this unit gives you
access to unlimited bland food but if
you're productive enough you can be
rewarded Ed with flavor there's a screen
that displays the amount of days that's
left in your sentence and while there
aren't any doors there's sensors that
ensure that there's only one person in a
cell otherwise you'll get fried the
sanitation areas are right before you
enter the work room and all of this is
to limit the amount of movement from
work directly to
[Music]
yourselves but in this new model model
the facilities are split between these
smaller buildings surrounded by a
natural landscape all of this is
contained in this perimeter wall kind of
like a campus this means they can move
around rather than being restricted to
the same hallways day after day but what
does that mean for surveillance
historically security was achieved
through the architecture through the
spatial layout with windowless walls
locks fences even cameras and CC systems
let's call this static security but it
usually comes at the expense of creating
spaces that are kind of inhumane narina
5 Prison while it's very technologically
advanced it still operates on the
principles of static security which
allows them to have this insane 1 to 100
guard to prisoner ratio but despite all
the rigorous physical and psychological
control mechanisms static security
failed to spot the communication between
the prisoners and this was potentially
an oversight on on the architects who
maybe try to add a little bit too much
Humanity to this prison technically if
we're strictly abiding by the principles
of static security these windows are not
necessary in fact it became the Fatal
flaw of this design cuz allowing them to
look outside the inmates could get a
sense of the scale of the prison and
understand just how many of them there
were and maybe even start to communicate
with each other so without a design
that's 100% bulletproof static security
has some major limitations especially
because it can antagonize and
potentially provoke the
inmates but in Halden and in the other
Humane prisons that we looked at they've
come up with a layer of security that's
invisible that allows them to reduce the
amount of static security at Holden they
call this Dynamic security but
essentially it's the relationship
between the inmates and the staff
created intentionally through workshops
and activities but it only works if we
flip the role of the architecture from a
surveiller to a facilitator by breaking
up the massing and creating a diversity
of spaces you facilitate movement and
interaction by using colors and warm
materials it helps regulate mood and
create a sense of comfort by placing
Windows strategically for daylight and
Views and even views onto the cells of
other inmates you reduce stress and
improve mental health they can track the
days and the seasons and it gives the
inmates a psychological connection to
the outside
[Music]
world in this very constrained
environment The Prisoner actually builds
a very intimate relationship with their
space and it can either facilitate
growth or lead to a complete decline and
Beyond this I think our approach to
prison says a lot about us as a society
do we believe in the potential for
change in every person is there room for
dignity and healing and Redemption even
for the worst criminals what do you guys
think let me know in the
[Music]
comments